good morning millennials
welcome back to the morning toast happy
thursday i hope everyone is having a
peaceful and wonderful week
it is a beautiful day here in new york
and we are here to entertain we are here
to entertain it is a beautiful day and
i'm having a beautiful
warm enchanted morning because t-h-e-o
finally came to yerandi i haven't sat
with him in so long i feel like he
smells the other pup on me
definitely the betrayal the betrayal
like finding lipstick on your husband's
neck
no i know but i'm just so excited all he
has to do is wait one more day because
tomorrow is my birthday
you haven't really spoken about it that
much i know i haven't really because
it's just like
what a terrible week to have a birthday
yeah but
all i want for my birthday is to get all
of the nibblings together
and so theo and bruno are going to meet
tomorrow and i just feel like there's
going to be something so special that
transpires between them
and that is the gift that i want for my
birthday truly like i'm done with
material items
not completely but like for the most
part but that's really all i want for my
birthday like if the nibblings can't be
there i don't want it no i
100 feel that i think the energy that
they will make together will
kind of radiate throughout the country
and i think that that's what the country
needs and i think it's going to be
really good for everyone
i think it's going to be so special so
that's what i'm looking forward to and
obviously thco like knew
you know yet auntie's turning 28
tomorrow i'll throw her a freaking bone
here yeah and lay with her and lay with
her
also speaking of vietnamese turning 28
tomorrow this is going to be our last
show of the week there will be no show
tomorrow since we'll be celebrating the
gift that truly keeps on giving which is
the birth of jackie ashrae wow thank you
so much
it's i'm excited i'm looking forward for
my birthday
to pass everyone's like what do you want
to do what do you want to do i'm like
nothing nothing
yeah for real like seriously nothing
stupid do you feel this way about
quarantine birthdays or
birthdays in general because i feel like
birthdays in general are a mix of like
highs and lows
i agree about birthdays in general being
highs and lows but usually it's like
whatever gifts i get like those are
really my gifts like and i'll wear them
forever and i'll have them forever but
because the most material items like
don't satiate me in the way that i used
to like
there's really it's just too much
pressure and like it's just going
to be a letdown so i just
i'll spend my day doing what i know i
love which is just having the family
together
some good steeny vibes music it's been a
minute yeah it's been a minute since all
of the vibes were staining yeah and
bruno's never experienced stevie vibes
which is a crowd
huge for him which is a crying shame he
doesn't even know like the family unit
that he has
yeah waiting for him so the day is
really about bruno it's not about me
you know what that's when you know
you've become a mother yeah yo
mama that's what i always say to bruno
yo mama's here oh my god
that's hilarious um we have a great show
for you guys today real housewives of
orange county was on last night jackie
watched the black pink netflix
documentary
that she's just like been it's been
oozing out of her she's dying she's just
it has been like i've been
slowly creeping up on blackpink stanhood
and i always knew it was like meant for
me
i just never had the time the bandwidth
to like listen to the albums watch the
documentary
the documentary was so good so cute you
get like a backstory on all four of the
girls
it's amazing four yeah there's four i
just assume like all k-pop groups have
like eight people no so
they talk about their training process
they've all trained to be in this group
for
um between four and six years most of
them like five years
yeah it's like this whole training and
they started with a lot of other
trainees thinking they were going to be
a big group
but then the magic of the four of them
became black pink
and they're so talented and it's such
it's so enjoyable to watch the singing
and the dancing they're even dabbling in
songwriting they're just really really
cute sweet girls who really genuinely
get along
and i also have so much respect for them
because they wrote a song about
theo and i'm sure you've probably heard
it yeah hit you with that doo doo doo
doo doo
and his favorite song it's the only song
about theo
that is in the k-pop genre and it slaps
so for that reason
[Music]
only the best for crunchy angel dora
yeah he has a few like really
great songs about him and i love
listening to them
me too i mean that's why i have my ipod
i'm always just like running around the
streets
listening to either sometimes i do a
little
theodora
crunchy angel dora beautiful precious
dora
one and only dora bruno's cousin dora
love of my life dora sweet sweet dora
soft and luscious dora luscious lips
adora
sexy mantora fuzzy boy dora
floppy ears dora smelt mandora
sexy chunky dora beautiful lipstick
eyes nose dora beautiful hips dora
crunchy munchylicious dora sleepy boy
dora
oh i could sing about him all day but i
won't but the black pink song is
actually called
do perfect perfect so any group that
respects
to do i respect as well it's a good
documentary if you're in the business of
concise documentaries that showcase the
triple threats
of rosie jisoo lisa and jenny
who okay one of my favorite movie genres
is celebrity documentaries i think
they're like so interesting
what are some of your favorite ones i
would say like my top
three are piece of work joan rivers
gaga five foot two and
i don't know for me
um it's hard i would need to go back i
would need to look at my netflix history
you know what i was actually thinking
netflix should have like your your like
viewing history where it shows like all
the times that you like paused and
resumed
and i'm sure that they have it somewhere
that they're using against you in some
way
but i just love when they share that
data i love data i love data data
data also sean mendes is coming out with
a netflix documentary wonder i watch the
trailer yeah it looks um
like really emo and i guess that's the
point of all celebrity documentaries
it's like you see a person on stage or
on screen and like there's so much more
to them
but this one was giving me he was really
giving me like actor vibes like it was
seemed really weird
yeah so you know you never know what's
gonna happen in life but i can tell you
that i won't be watching that
documentary oh i probably will
even though the name is just not working
for me because it's the name of that
really sad jacob tremblay movie
room wonder oh there's so many
wonder it's it's called wonder which i
get it's the name of his new song but
like i just think of that really sad
movie where like i literally couldn't
even get through the trailer without
crying
yeah that was a really good movie should
be necessary viewing for kids i really
want to go to the movies like it's
killing me there's not even movies out
there right right
well um anything else you want to chat
about um
no other than that it was just another
lovely day with bruno gearing up for him
to meet his cousins
oh you know with the help of you and
your husband actually
i you've curated i'm getting there i
made a i made some progress in the
curation of a living room
vibe because for personal reasons i can
no longer hang out in my bed all the
time
and so i got new candles i got my led
lights that zach recommended
and they need some work i need to rewire
some things but they're there
well my vibe cultivation is going a
little too well because i keep
passing out on my couch you know i was
texting you like for a few hours
yesterday and you weren't answering and
i'm like i know she fell asleep i fell
asleep for two hours but it's also
because i'm on a new schedule
i wake up earlier because of bruno so we
always take a nap together during the
day
and i'm having a really easy time
falling asleep at night knock on wood
so i'm kind of feeling it yeah it's
definitely like my peloton has
been suffering and like my diet is
suffering but
i'm getting great nap time with bruno so
yeah and that's just like
those are memories you really can't put
a price on so i think it's okay
yeah and like he's just we're attached
at the hip you should see us together
like when we're getting ready in the
morning he's like
telling you what to wear he's telling me
what to wear he loves to chew on my
slippers and you know what they're his
slippers now
yeah and he's just a really special guy
i will
i think i'm gonna put it out there i'm
gonna bring him next week okay i'm gonna
put it out there i'm gonna commit to it
it's hard i know that it's hard but he's
so little and tiny like
i just like shove him in my arm i have a
carrier for him if i need one
i think i can do it okay i'm gonna do it
um
i just didn't want here to be the first
time him and theo meet because i don't
want him to think they're co-workers
like i want him to know their family
their family yeah no and it's those
types of relationships are really hard
um
on young sons so i understand yeah so
exciting to look forward to very
fabulous very fabulous and speaking of
fabulous we have a fabulous show for you
guys
we have some interesting stories so
without further ado
it is time for the past five stories
that you need to know before you wake up
and take a bite out of your morning
toast
and today's sponsor is actually very
appropriate because i feel like all week
we've been talking about
how to cultivate vibes in your house how
to like redo your whole house like
without really doing anything especially
like if you rent like me and that's
where today's sponsor comes in
frame bridge they make it easier and
more affordable than ever to frame your
things without ever leaving your house
from art prints and posters to the
photos sitting on your phone you can
frame bridge
just about anything it's also the
perfect way to give easy and thoughtful
gifts in just minutes you can turn a
photo from your phone into one of your
best gifts gifts ever
here's how it works just go to
framebridge.com and upload your photo or
they'll send you packaging to safely
mail in your physical pieces
preview your item online in dozens of
frame styles and gallery wall layouts
choose your favorite or get free
recommendations from their talented
designers
then the experts at frame bridge will
custom frame your item and deliver your
finished piece
straight to your to anyone on your gift
list a handcrafted personal gift from
frame bridge
starts at 39 and all shipping is free
plus our listeners can get 15 off their
first order
at framebridge.com when you they use the
promo code toast
so i feel like first of all it's the
perfect gift for anyone who's like
sentimental it's a great gift idea
and i was like walking around my house
yesterday i'm like i have like no framed
pictures of my family like
i've art on the wall and like one
picture from my wedding and it's just
like kind of sad it's like
who lives here a ghost yeah so i go then
thea and then it's like getting pictures
like printed and then like
sent to a framer it's like a whole thing
and then it costs like a thousand
dollars
so honestly frame bridge is great
because you can upload pictures directly
from your phone which is where all my
good pictures are anyway
100 i have a few frame bridge items in
my home one of them you guys have
probably seen it because it's like
behind my vanity it's a stunning photo
of me
oh yeah um and frame bridge just like
knocked it out of the park it literally
looks like artwork yeah it does
um so you can get started today frame
your photos or send someone else the
perfect gift
just go to framebridge.com use the promo
code toast to save an additional 15
off your first order just go to
framebridge.com
promo code toast that's framebridge.com
promo code toast sign on get premium
frames in your home like they make a
huge difference and they can all
also match each other and that just
makes the vibe on point
and it just makes your home warm like hi
there humans who live here
stunning beautiful humans with great
taste in photos and clothing
totally okay first story some really
crazy news hillsong pastor and justin
bieber's one-time spiritual confidant
carl lentz and one time guest on the
morning breath
yeah a man who made a really big
impression on the two of us has been
fired for moral
failures okay also he happened to be a
guest on the morning breath on halloween
when you and i were dressed as each
other and you know what he didn't judge
us
he was so like fun like honestly really
really nice and cool
i did have an experience with him um
years later that
i was like a little shady you know the
experience with shady i thought he just
like pretended to remember you even
though you felt like he didn't he
pretended to not know me that's what it
was
okay but when he met us on halloween you
were dressed as me you were wearing a
red wig
we had kept in touch via instagram and
he was out to dinner
with haley bieber and simon so of course
i'm so thirsty i'm gonna go see hallie
bieber
i go up to simon i give him a hug and
i'm like girl
literally pretended like he didn't know
who i was then as i'm leaving the
restaurant he runs out and he was like
oh hey
like why don't you see me not in front
of haley not in front of haley
i don't know about all that and
unfortunately the story is not about you
all i'm saying is i'm just giving
context carl lentz a mega church pastor
known for his high profile celebrity
followers and friends and known for his
appearance on the morning breath has
repeatedly been fired from his
reportedly sorry because we fired your
fire fired fire
as a reporter we were totally watching
this story right okay let's start over
okay carl lens has reportedly been fired
from his position at hillsong in part
due to past
moral failures the mega church founder
brian houston
announced carl's termination on
wednesday quote today hillsong church
church east coast advised our
congregation that we have terminated the
employment of pastor carl lentz
this action was not taken lightly and
was done in the best interests of
everyone
including pastor carl houston added that
carl's firing comes after ongoing
discussions in relation to leadership
issues
and breaches of trust plus a recent
revelation of moral
failures the senior pastor added that it
would not be appropriate to go into
further detail about what led to carl's
departure from the church
i mean what that's a big announcement
right what an ominous will so reason
i was reading comments and feedback from
people who are like a part of
hillsong or just like mega churches in
general and they say that like
moral failure is like christian talk for
cheating on your wife
oh like it's very like it was very
intentional language that's what they
say i mean i don't know obviously i'm
not a part of a church but
this just like the way they were saying
and people who are from this community
were like
this is what you say when someone cheats
on their rights okay well thank you for
that information because i was just like
not confirmed not confirmed moral
failure could
literally be anything it could be like
anything from
talking [ __ ] about someone to murdering
someone yeah so
thank you for that context that that
makes things make a little more sense
but this is i feel like carl lentz
at least for me the way i perceive
hillsong like he is hillsong no
he's [ __ ] he's one of the yes he's
one of the biggest foxes
of hillsong and so even though it has
felt like in recent years been less
visible
well so then i went down a rabbit hole
and
he's kind of been like the most
controversial member because he runs
around with celebrities
there was a picture of him and justin
bieber at a club not a club a bar
taking a shot of alcohol which was just
like you know no no
so i think he's kind of been like the um
the rebel
yeah i think that's in part what drew
people to the church i think obviously
like the celebrity aspect of it
really drew people and i don't know
about enough about like mega churches
and
there are like tons of articles on like
why they're problematic by the end of
the day like i live for the hillsong
music
and i don't belong to a church so like
it's not my business
but i think that if he did cheat on his
wife it's like a huge sin
in christianity but also just like in
the world um and i think that they took
a stand
and from the reception that i'm reading
of people in the
like in the church they're not all too
upset by this announcement
okay like i just think it was his time
you know just like the san francisco
49ers
yeah and it wasn't their time oh it
wasn't whose time was it it was
travis kelsey's time kansas city chiefs
to me
the kansas wait what did i say the 49ers
no no you were right and you're
remembering of when it's not someone's
time
are those of the teams it was 49ers
versus the kansas city chiefs
you said san francisco it is not your
time okay that's confusing because i
feel like both of those teams are red
yeah uh yes sort of okay sorry so it
wasn't their time
it wasn't their time and by the way was
i right about that or was i right no you
were
dead on it wasn't the 49ers time i feel
like carl lentz is like the pete
campbell of hillsong like going out
who's pete campbell from mad men like
he's like in the in the agency like he
goes out wines and dines the clients
you know brings in the big fish but he
doesn't actually do anything at the
institution like the the creative work
but he
is like the face yeah no and i feel like
for a while it was really really working
and
to be honest like he's pr he i mean i
don't know anything about what it means
to be a good pastor but
i feel like he was like a really good
pastor because even when he was with us
he was
very persuasive and i'm like i love
christ he's like he almost
got me in the door you know he was very
persuasive and even the things that he
was saying
because what he was saying was like so
um
what's the word i'm looking for like
universal like yes it wasn't about
christ it was just about like being a
good person i was like i love this man
like
i was like yeah yeah tell me more tell
me more and i feel like that's what a
good pastor does like he really speaks
to people speaks their souls speaks to
all people
yes and is a leader and i feel like for
a while he was doing a really good job
and maybe he just like got
caught up about like with the justin
bieber of it all but then
there was a weirdness there was more
weirdness layers because
selena and justin both used to be
members of hillsong there were a lot of
things being said
about mr lentz as it pertains to the
justin haley celine of it all
so i'm not gonna go into any rumors
because i'm not trying to get sued by
hillsong but
just you could do your research there's
a lot of
there's a lot of rumors questions yeah
rumors
unclear i'm tired of rumors starting i'm
sick of being
i'm tired of people want me saying what
they want about me
what a good song good song with an
important message an important message
justice for lindsay lohan's very
short-lived singing career
yeah but she gave us so many precious
gems so much and i think maybe the best
she gave us is
you're it you're the ultimate
it's automatic i'm sure of it no light
so don't even try to tell me that you're
not the guy
cause i've been waiting all my life for
someone just like you
but you're it you're the ultimate
no no no no no no no no no
no no no no no no no
i am jack black honestly that's a
compliment yeah
credits the energy of jack black and
school of rock is something that
everyone should
wake up and try and emulate 100
positivity
music and like doing the bare minimum to
get by
and having a severe case of stick it to
the manniosis it's so contagious
i think we have stick it to the madness
i was born with it
it's genetic that's why we both have it
but it's really bad it is bad but
hopefully it is contagious we can rub it
off on all of you
that is probably the number one content
upper we forgot to add to the list
add it to the list it is coming soon
good
and honestly have you ever seen it on
broadway no stellar
the kids are stellar the campers the
campers are stellar
okay cool i'll definitely be checking
that out yeah
okay next story um some sad news lamar
odom and sabrina park call off their
engagement as he has some things that he
alone has to work through it's like such
a fake answer
yeah i'm i'm bummed out about this i was
really happy i didn't even know he was
engaged
yes you did we reported it and like
chloe was good and he was good and i
think everyone was good
but lamar odom and fiance sabrina parr
have called off their engagement nearly
one year after announcing their plans to
marry
she broke the news on instagram on
wednesday night saying y'all know i'm
honest and transparent
so i have to be the first to let you
guys know that i'm no longer engaged to
lamar
this has been a difficult decision for
me to make but it is the best for myself
and my children
lamar has some things that he alone has
to work through she continued adding
that she loves him dearly
but is no longer to be able to be by his
side while he seeks the help he so
desperately
no that of course sounds like
he might have relapsed with his
addiction yeah we know that the former
nba player has struggled with drug
addiction in the past but it was not
clear what things he's dealing with now
oh my god no i'm so upset like i take
this really hard and personally and i
really hope he's okay
i hope he's okay and it's just like
weird because
i don't know and i think maybe a lot of
people like turn to chloe like help but
it's also like
chloe's in in a different place in her
life she's a kid now
she's back with tristan and it's like
it's really sad and i just don't feel i
feel like lamar odom doesn't have like a
lot of people around him like
his friend jamie who really was an
enabler he passed away right yeah
um and and his he had a very troubled
relationship with his dad
and his mom had passed away and he lived
with his grandma and then his grandma
passed away
and i just feel like he doesn't have a
lot of like good people around him who
are like looking out for him
and that makes me really sad that does
make me sad i hope that he
has a community of people that he can
turn to and i think there's a chance
that like
the kardashians and chris might be some
of those people
that they've always that he's always in
their lives going to be in their lives
you know they're
they're very much like that your family
you are family forever regardless
of circumstances changing right even if
you don't have kids together which is
like obviously why scott's still like
such a
integral part of the family and like a
cast member on the show but i think that
like
even the way they like are still like so
close with french montana when him and
chloe dated for like five minutes yeah i
think that they
find people who like they trust and who
have become part of their family and
they never let them go and i really hope
that
they can reach out and get him the help
that he needs
like i hope that's not the problem she's
referring to it sounds like it is
yeah very upsetting yeah
next story some some news for fans of
the affair
so not for myself okay but no this is
this is news for tv mysteries like this
was so bizarre when it happened
ruth wilson reveals she quit the affair
because she didn't feel
safe so if you don't watch the affair it
was like a seven season show
and literally at the fifth season ruth
wilson who played allison who was
an integral she made the affair yeah it
was she was a very
they were four main characters she was
one of them um she just
up and disappeared from the show it was
so bizarre they like wrote her out
and it was very weird because she was an
important player like
of all the people who i could have taken
out she was not going to be one of them
even though i didn't even like her
character she just literally poof
vanished poof i never made it to that
part but oh you didn't
no i i finished it i know i i could not
i
watched like maybe four seasons i think
and like i i found it to be
so unbearable oh i liked it but she's
offering insight into her abrupt 2018
departure from showtime's hit series the
affair
oh and we never heard like we never got
a reason no statement so now we're
finally hearing the 38 year old actress
said she quote didn't feel safe
according to the rap citing an interview
with uk based
stylist magazine published on tuesday
it's very niche well the reason i
haven't gone into the affair is that i
haven't worked out how to discuss it
there's a lot of noise and anger
surrounding it and really the power
rests with me to choose how i discuss my
life and my experiences
what's important to me is to say that i
did speak up i did have a voice i did
stand up for myself
there was a situation on the affair
where things didn't feel right and i
dealt with them and i managed to protect
myself
at the time of her exit from the show
which as its name suggests is about two
sexual affairs
it was considered to be under mysterious
circumstances when asked why she signed
she cited an nda as preventing her from
discussing it
then in late 2019 a hollywood reporter
story reported crew members accounts of
a hostile work environment
on the set regarding the handling of the
show's nudity and sex scenes
the showrunner sarah tream responded
with an op-ed calling wilson difficult
and not apologizing oh i didn't know
that i mean the show had a lot of nudity
and a lot of sex and
um i guess you never really think about
like what the uh atmosphere is like when
they're filming that yeah
and it has to be very uncomfortable and
there should be all these precautions
taken
and i'm guessing that there wasn't yeah
so
a little answer full circle i didn't
even know that she
winds up leaving the show because it
makes no sense she's like an integral
part
yeah you can not even conceive it even
though the season spoiler alert if
you're ever gonna watch it are you never
gonna finish it
nope where she leaves the show she gets
murdered by this crazy
man she met in a a and the whole um
she's missing and the whole season is
like what happened to her and you don't
think she's gonna die because it's
allison
and then she and it actually is like
amazing television that actually sounds
good and the way that like you see
how she dies is told from all these
different perspectives and she met this
guy in aaa and he had ptsd so like
you get his perception of it and he sees
things so differently because he's
unstable and it actually is very well
done even though i was sad when she died
that sounds very very good yeah and i
probably still won't watch it but i'm
sure that if i had made it there
that's like because you wouldn't expect
a main character to die so you would
think she would have been found
so that for that reason i like to be
fair
also the fact that it brought joshua
jackson like into my life at a time when
i i so desperately needed him and i
didn't know him from anywhere else like
for that i'm so grateful for that
handsome sexy man
yeah he's a good one i saw him in um
best buy once with diane from
inglorious bastards what's her name i
get all the diane's confused uh
she's not keaton no he's not lane no
she's not krueger krueger
yeah so she and joshua jackson were
invest by buying a tv once looking oh my
god so cute like you could have died
like hugging the aisles like
looking for a tv and i followed them
around the store for a little bit and
then they left they didn't get anything
oh i wonder what they were looking for a
td oh but obviously best buy did not
have the best buys for them even though
like
what more are you looking for no like if
you literally walk into best buy and for
a tv and like can't find what you need
like what you need doesn't exist
yeah that's weird no one's remember the
story i know
um are we looking different today um
you're always looking so beautiful
sounding and smart but did you do
something particularly different your
smile is
gleaming well i'm so glad you brought
that up thanks to bruce
i'm gleaming all over the city gleaming
shining walling living it up in the city
okay so bruce is something we talk about
here all the time and i'm so grateful
because it's literally the most fabulous
product
and if it weren't for the morning toast
i wouldn't have known about it and i
literally wouldn't have brushed my teeth
this morning and last night with my
super cute millennial pink brush
electric toothbrush
now why is this toothbrush different
from all other toothbrushes one because
it works really well and two it doesn't
cost over two hundred dollars
like most electric toothbrushes do and
it has like a
small stand where it charges so it
doesn't like bulk up bulk up all this
bacteria which i've had from other
electric toothbrushes where the whole
thing just becomes like
my saliva no and it's like magnetic it's
very clean yeah like
it's so small and you can just get the
bacteria off
if it ever builds up for a dentist
quality clean at home don't brush your
teeth
brush them brushing your teeth can be a
chore but brushing is fun and 100 times
as effective
bruce cleans your teeth at 31 000
movements a minute many electric
toothbrushes are barely a step up from
manual toothbrushes
some can do a good job but they cost
over 200 bruce delivers premier sonic
wave technology without the markups big
electric toothbrushes tack on
get 15 off your bruce today when you use
code toast at bruce.com i got a bunch of
dms being like what was the name of the
bruce
like what is the code listen up
bruce.com b-r-u-u-s-h-dot-com you want
to get 15
off you have to use the promo code toast
you can try it 90 days risk free and get
a two year warranty
bruce.com promo code toast don't be
walking around with [ __ ] in your teeth
it's not nice
do not okay next story a little bit of
what the kids are up to
kids slamming other kids ariana grande
slams tick tockers for partying during
the pandemic
ariana grande is taking a firm position
against tick-tockers the 2017
singer called out social media
influencers during an interview on the
zak sang show on friday
dragging popular l.a bar saddle ranch as
well she said
of all the things that we could have
done couldn't we have just stayed home
for a few more weeks like all the other
countries that were fine
and are better than we are did we really
all need to go to [ __ ] saddle ranch
that badly that we couldn't have waited
for the deathly pandemic to pass
we all really needed to put on our
cowboy boots and ride a mechanical bull
that bad
we all needed that instagram post that
badly tick tock influencer dixie dimlio
was asked on sunday about
her comments and i guess she was talking
about dixie
dixie said i don't really know what to
think i mean she's right
she's right yeah she's a queen i love
her oh
another influencer addison ray was asked
about ariana's comments and she
responded
i think it's fair for her to say that i
think it's understandable i definitely
have been not going i just have been
trying to stay in and work out
i've been working out a lot and also
preparing for my movie
um not what is she in not another she's
all that he's all that he's all that
she added that saddle ranch is like a
tick tock tick tocker's playground right
playground right now though um i think
just shower noted that
addison was spotted at saddle ranch
twice in the past month um so yes saddle
ranch i've noticed on tick tock and like
all the youtubers for those of us who
are turning 28 tomorrow what is it it's
just like a bar it's like an outdoor
restaurant bar i guess they have a
mechanical bowl i didn't know that
um they have outdoor seating and it's
just like a real hot spot for
tick-tockers like if you're
if you're there on any week night like
after 8pm like you can see someone from
the hype house tana mojo like everyone
goes there
i mean it looks not like the most
coveted friendly place but it's outdoor
dining essentially everyone sits at
their table they have like beer funnels
like you get cool drinks
um and i don't know i've never been
inside but i really
it it sounds really no tana mojo goes
there all the time and like it honestly
looks so fun
um there's a picture of it here it looks
fun and it's like
country it's brilliant yeah it sounds
fabulous and if they are
being outside and they're open their
business
operating under the law following the
guidelines i don't know i think but when
all these kids go it becomes like a
whole thing like with
paparazzi and like that's where i feel
like it becomes like a spectacle and
like maybe a little unsafe
but the restaurant itself like if you're
just dining there it's like an outdoor
dining experience but when
it becomes like a whole fiasco when like
they pull up in their party buses with
like 30 kids and then the paparazzi
comes in like everyone here at southern
rancho all the girls from
usc like come running you know what i
mean like let's see
you know that's what happens i
officially feel old um
i think this is second we we gotta go
when we go to l.a
it sounds like so up our alley and
they're getting dressed up in cowboy
boots and hats i guess
i didn't notice that but i just noticed
people like sitting outside drinking
like looking like they're having a good
time
that sounds within the guidelines within
their rights to me i think this is a
little lame avari i'm not going to lie
is that certain shade but i also want to
talk about it because i want to talk
about her new album we haven't had a
chance to discuss it yet
because i have not had a chance to
listen to one like of it i listened to
half of it i thought it was good you can
definitely tell and i read some of her
interviews like
you know everybody loved the thank you
next album but it was hard for her to
sing to her
it's all about her heartbreak and this
is a new
chapter of her life where she's just
like feeling good
honestly a lot of it is like very sexual
like talking about like all the sex that
she's having with her new man's i'm
assuming
and she's in a really good place it
sounds like and i think it's like
oh that's a happier album
even though like when i think of thank
you next i'm like bop bop bop and i
don't hear
all of the pain as much but there's a
lot but but there is a lot
yeah uh no i mean i think that's what
we've been saying for like the past few
years it's like all we want is for
ariana grande
to take a nap be in a good head space i
think she
was on this like hamster wheel for so
long whereas like she was filled with so
much heartbreak so therefore she was
like making so much music and that music
took her
on tour took her to all these places but
at the end of the day that heartbreak
she really needed to like
take some time for herself so i actually
feel like of all the people who are
probably thriving in quarantine ariana
grande is most definitely one of them
because she's the type of person who
like
needed time at home like yeah she worked
so much non-stop she was dealing with so
much
mental health-wise and i actually like i
feel like this album is probably
the best head space she's ever been yeah
and you can feel the like lightness
right from the album i also want to say
that the aesthetic
and vibe and looks that she is putting
out there for this album
are unparalleled like sickening
stunning gorgeous i love like the retro
vibe
she's switching up the ponytail a little
bit but still sticking it's very short
and it's like more of like a flip like a
60s 75 inch but she's still sticking to
her ponytail roots i
absolutely love what she's done with the
place ponytail roots
yeah yeah actually was watching a video
yesterday
um of her like on youtube it came up
with my suggested and her hair was down
and i'm
like who is this person yeah she's a
different human when her hair is down
she is i love that pony though i know
you got kind of over it but like
i hope she wears that ponytail i don't
get over it i think that
it needs to evolve with her and with the
times so i'm actually really digging
this one but for a while like the long
pony like it was too long and it was
went on too long oh i love it so much
okay our fifth and final story the
witches which is a new
movie that just premiered on hbo max
starring
anne hathaway it's based on the rolled
doll book
it's 20 20 i cannot pronounce
he's the rural and ben is always
correcting me
are you guys always talking about roll
doll no but we've been playing jeopardy
a lot and whenever they come up with
like book categories like literally the
only authors i know are like
dr seuss and rule doll and i'm like
rodol
raul doll and ben is like it's rule i'm
like
is it raw doll it's ruled oh
and he also wrote charlie and the
chocolate factory and matilda i think
right
i don't know about that one okay i think
so but anyways the witch's 2020 remake
is getting heat for how it portrays
disabilities
warner brothers has issued an apology
about a character's depiction in the hbo
max movie the witches after backlash
from people with disabilities
activists targeted the film directed by
oscar winner
robert zemikus who did forrest gump for
playing up a split hand
on the grand high witch character played
by anne hathaway
on monday paralympian amy marin called
out the movie on twitter
saying please educate yourselves on limb
differences and the support the idea
that you are
hashtag not a witch because you look
different you can also actively support
the limb difference community by using
words that describe us as people
as it's not the difference that defines
us you know what it does seem very
strange to me that there's like
virtually no representation in like
hollywood films for people with
disabilities
and like when there is she's a witch
like if there was an
overwhelming amount of parts for people
with all different types of
disabilities and one of them was a witch
i'm like okay but if it's like the only
representation like i actually see
why this upsets people and it would
upset me too definitely and i think
warner brothers sees that now they put
out a statement that said we the
filmmakers and warner brothers pictures
are deeply saddened to learn that our
depiction
of the fictional characters in the
witches could upset people with
disabilities
and regret any offense caused uh the
statement goes on
but they're definitely taking
responsibility for this complete
oversight and
everyone involved i guess no one it's
just crazy that like so many people can
work on a movie and it can go through so
many like
channels and nobody can see how like
this might be offensive you know yeah
definitely it's always bizarre to me
when like offensive things like make air
because like corporate like television
commercials like so many hoops that they
have to jump through in order to get
that commercial on air it's like nobody
thought to like stop and think for a
second
yeah definitely kendall jenner pepsi
commercial
right like those were such simpler times
yeah it's a star-studded movie though
and hathaway is the lead but it also
features octavia spencer stanley tucci
also my stanley chu google alert didn't
go off for this one stanley tucci got
his own show
on cnn and it's like traveling italy
with stanley tucci and trying different
foods like an anthony bourdain vibe
delicious i know we gotta subscribe
kristin chenoweth chris rock jazeera
bruno
um and it's also the screenplay was
co-written by a blackish creator
kenya barris and guillermo del toro who
oh wow won all of those awards right
no um shape of water i get them confused
shape of water um now let's dive into
our tv recap segment because
it'd be more different who's the guy
from the artist the silent movie member
and he won everything okay give me a
minute i i'm always exciting
i'm gonna what i was the phrase i was
trying to say yesterday
what your whistle which i couldn't
figure out but then someone
gotta know okay the artist
there was that year where the artists
swept the oscars and this guy like won
all of them
michael hasana vision
yes okay so it's not guillermo got it
okay they do sound different now that i
think about it
um okay tv recap segment i'm actually
really looking forward to talking about
real housewives
because we have two episodes to recap
because we didn't recap last week oh
true
and they actually go together really
nicely because of the big fight it was
blended really well
because of the sloppy chihuahua oh my
gosh
today's tv recap segment is brought to
you by better help is there something
interfering with your happiness or is
preventing you from achieving your goals
definitely my anxiety and stress are two
of those things better help will assess
your needs and match you with your own
licensed professional therapist where
you can start communicating in under 48
hours
it's not a crisis line it's not
self-help it is professional counseling
done very securely online there's a
broad range of expertise available which
may not be locally available to you
the service is available for clients
worldwide where you can log in anytime
and send a message to your counselor
you'll get timely and thoughtful
responses plus you can schedule weekly
video or phone sessions
so you won't ever have to sit in an
uncomfortable waiting room as with
traditional therapy
i mean these are very high stress times
i think everyone's feeling really really
anxious and i think a lot of people in
quarantine
have taken up therapy um and betterhelp
is just a great resource because you can
find someone who may be available in
florida if you're in new york and you do
it all online it's all super secure
you can feel safe you can communicate
like however you feel comfortable doing
so whether that's like video chats or
texts i feel like it's really hard
sometimes to make that first move to
yeah find counseling and to seek it out
but with better health like it makes it
really easy
let this be the sign that if you've been
thinking about it like maybe
it's the time better help is committed
to facilitating great therapeutic
matches
so they make it easy and free to change
counselors if needed it's more
affordable than traditional offline
counseling and financial aid is
available
better help wants you to start living a
happier life today we have a special
offer for the morning toast listeners
if you want to get 10 off your first
month of better help go to
betterhelp.com
toast so many people have been using
betterhelp that they are recruiting and
additional counselors in all 50 states
so make sure you get the help that you
need if you need so at
better health b-e-t-t-e-r-help h-e-l-p
dot com toast make sure to use that link
if you want to get 10 off your first
month at betterhelp.com
love it real housewives of orange county
so can i just say like this season is
really shaping up
much better than i thought it was going
to be i actually think the group of
girls while i don't think that they
would be friends if it weren't for like
the last five of them
being on the show i do think that
there's potential for there to be real
friendships
100 and i think that potential truly
lies
in shannon storms fedor and emily like i
think there's so much potential there
i love i love emily like i've been
saying
forever that emily is gonna she's gonna
shine she's gonna shine she had an
eyeline davidson moment
and i think that we've gotten there i
think her husband are in a good place i
think he knows to shut the [ __ ] up and
not be on the show anymore
she needs to like let loose a little bit
and just embrace like the housewife's
vibe more and i think all of those
elements are adding up
to emily being just like the rising star
of this season and i'm just
i'm thrilled and she was on watch drop
inside last night
literally andy could not get over how
good she looked she
and he was like you look like khloe
kardashian she lightened her hair she
got her boob implants out and just like
has smaller boobs now so she said she's
like much
smaller on top and she lost a ton of
weight and she said her features have
like
changed so much she looks she always
looks amazing but she looked
just like so happy and like her boobs
are amazing oh my god i want to see
that's so exciting i love her i've
always loved her as an individual i
think she's just like a good thinker
a smart cookie and a good friend but
she's always had a hard time like
blending with
the women and it is nice to see i still
like feel really defensive of her when
they're like fun emily fun emily because
it's because it's mean
because by the way i don't think she
finds it offensive and i think she like
loves when people are like
fun emily's here i think like she wants
to embrace her fun emily morris because
people like fun emily when they didn't
like emily but it just implies that like
she's not
fun totally uh so i'm happy for her and
i'm glad
i like her friendship with gina i just
my heart really
is breaking for bronwyn and i feel
really badly
for her she's obviously going through so
much personally
she is not in the best spot with the
rest of the group to be taking all of
this on
and i really feel bad for her like
she's sharing everything like yeah
really deep
and i think that a lot of people who
maybe aren't sober and i didn't know
this either
like don't understand like there is this
period where like you do have
withdrawals from alcohol like i just
assume withdrawals are like
for drugs but no you're gonna
withdrawals from alcohol and i think
like
it like kind of puts you in this like
unbalanced place and she was acting
crazy
and i think that there's like a very
good explanation for why she was acting
that way yes but also she said something
that really resonated with me where it's
like
she because she's always drunk she's
never she doesn't really feel a lot of
she hasn't been feeling a lot of the
things whether it's an uncomfortable
conversation like
you know alcohol just like smooths
everything over so
now being sober she's feeling every
single feeling and that is
really overwhelming yeah especially when
she's in a place with all the girls
where
she's they're pittsfield feelings you
know she's not the toast of the town
right now
do you think shannon said the thing
about gina's house yes
me too a hundred percent and you know
who i just
like listen like just ride with
and when like she like kill it on like
kelly dodd's position in the group where
she's like
being a friend to bronwyn being a friend
like she's really she's no stake in
anything
and she just like sees the situation for
what it is and she's like yeah shannon
probably said that
of course i just i'm like really feeling
kelly donna and also it is the season of
kelly dobb like a new new house new man
new house new man scenes with her hands
dying
at the scenes what do you love about
rick he just does whatever i say rick
you need to put this away for me rick
can you bring this upstairs
i mean that's literally me and ben it
was so
[ __ ] funny it was so funny i guess we
hadn't had seen him on the show before
and
i guess we i wasn't i didn't think about
it but i probably would have assumed he
wouldn't come on this show because he
doesn't even live in oc
and he's on tv he's like a celebrity
he's a news correspondent right so
sometimes you don't like
get into housewives drama when you have
like other seriously you're also a
public figure
yeah no i thought the same thing but i
think their house is so nice her house
looks just like shannon's is anybody
else and i love that like even though
she hates everything about where she's
living like she's doing it for jolie
yeah no and jolie like gone to the good
school like there's something so
at moments so unlikable about kelly dodd
but she has these
really like endearing moments and i
think like when she's with her kids and
she's
when she's in a happy place in her life
she's like the best version of herself
and that's why she's not getting in the
weeds like starting fights throwing
drinks at people because she's so happy
and i also feel that way about shanna
madur there is nobody worse in the world
when they're in a bad place than shannon
bedor i agreed
she takes everything out on everyone she
cannot think logically she is the
worst but when she's happy there's
nothing better she's happy she's fun
she's kissing her boyfriend she's having
drinks
and she's really just like this
happy-go-lucky person and
i think that her and kelly are getting
along now because they're both so happy
in their personal lives that what is
there to fight about
yeah let's just enjoy life together one
thing i didn't like that bronwyn did and
i get that she's going through a lot and
she honestly can't control how she feels
but
when she called and she didn't even know
that it was shannon's boyfriend's son
lemonade boy like that was so
disrespectful and i was actually really
glad
that it didn't just go by the wayside
like everyone when they heard it were
like what
that's a crazy thing to say i don't know
she was so flustered and she just won
her husband's like lemonade boy can you
get my husband let's talk about her
husband
i know i when he like stayed back to
defend her i was like
here for it and no no and then whenever
i was like he shouldn't have done that
he should have um
consult his wife he should have went
with her immediately
i don't know i i i could see how you
like both things work
because console your wife and a husband
talking to housewives alone
never works you always look like the
villain you always look like your man's
like he's just defending his wife like
his wife is so upset
she stormed out and like i didn't think
he said anything so crazy other than
like that was uncalled for
i just don't i just don't think when a
man on housewives is talking to the
women like without his wife present like
i just think it's always a recipe for
disaster i just don't think it's a
blanket statement like men and women can
talk men can defend their wives on
housewives
housewives it will always make them look
bad but i do have like respect for him
what
in that moment like i was fine with him
sticking up for his wife
what was weird to me though is like i
and i respected bronwyn for coming back
to have conversations i did not think
she was going to do that but while she
was doing that her husband was like in
the mix at the party
like this is no longer like a social
event for you guys like
you were here doing damage control yeah
bronwyn doesn't need to keep sending
people to go get her husband because he
can't leave
the party no totally like he wasn't
sticking with her at all yeah he was
just like not realizing like okay
our party our social socializing time is
over like
we are here to make amends business
please do not get distracted and i have
to send people to go for
you because i need to leave when i need
to leave let me ask you another question
do you think that shawn her husband
sent that text to gina trying to like
[ __ ] around no i mean
i think that he is an old man a
different sort of
cat i think that the way that people
text
is very different i think that like
there's a generational gap between gina
who grew up on texting and like knows
that it's just a mode of communication
versus him who like sends who overly
communicates clearly
the fact that he sent a wink and a
emoticon smiley and not an emoji like
tells me everything i need to know
yeah there are so many emojis that could
have been conveyed like
yeah sexy time and i think he was
actually just being like a decent person
right and bronwyn's right like when
you're telling everyone that story
you're forgetting the part that my
husband put you in an uber that's why he
was checking to make sure you got home
not like we were at a party together and
then like you just wanted to see where
what you were up to late night
he got you an uber home so you just want
to make sure you got home yeah i think
that she's totally blowing that out of
proportion and even if like
maybe at the time she felt that way the
fact that she can't see bronwyn's
perspective now of like you're going
around making my husband sound creepy
and i don't like that yeah so yeah i'm
mad at you i'm going to talk [ __ ] she's
that's unreasonable like i don't think
that that's so crazy and i think bronwyn
is literally admitting and owning
everything and
that's all we ever ask of people so i
think sometimes you just need to
and brahman's like a good girl you know
she has her faults but like i think
she's a nice
person and so sometimes you just need to
cut someone some slack give them a break
and another chance
and i think they're going to be dragging
this out longer than it needs to be
checked out i
also thought her husband um bringing
kelly the mezuzah was so
nice yeah it was just and so there were
a few different like he was actually in
the episode a lot and i think that like
they could stand to be apart a little
bit about something else
but that sort of thing just like made me
see his character like the same way he
would send a text
to gina that was entertaining really
friendly he's bringing a mezuzah to
kelly because she's with a jewish guy
which is such an it's
in it's such a nice thing to do such a
nice thing to do and hung it up for her
where it's like i
it takes me like months to hang up on me
you know it's really hard like i wish
bronwyn would send her a husband over to
hang up my mind it was really sweet i
agree with that
now i need to talk about the one thing i
did not like about this episode and that
is just
gina like gina jean and gina i can't
stand her
i feel like every time we are watching
her she's curling her hair or having her
hair curled
and it's so upsetting because her hair
is so dead she needs to take out all of
her extensions and just wear a wig for a
year
so that her hair can grow and be healthy
like she's she's like the picture of
what you're not supposed to do to your
hair like bleach it curl it hot iron and
like
never stop like yeah never stop with the
bleach never stop with the hot tools
like
it's a psa this is what happens when you
don't take care of your hair also like
if she is going to curl her hair all the
time i would love to see her use a
thicker wand we do
because the curls are like they're not
the right
length length and curliness like for the
length of her hair
yeah and i actually do find it
interesting how she's co-parenting with
her man's new girl and i actually really
appreciated her perspective of being
like yeah it's kind of weird but like
she picks up the kids from school and
like it's another person taking care of
the kids
i can go out to lunch like that's what
like co-parenting should be and so i
actually think it's really
admirable how they've come from what
happened at the reunion with like her
telling us about the domestic violence
case to like being civil and
taking care of the kids and like putting
the kids first like i think that's
really good
um but i there's just something so
i just can't with her she's just not it
yeah
i feel that i really do and sometimes
i'm like well i felt like she was
starting to have compassion for
bronwyn because her dad um was sober
also so i was like i wanted to see more
of that side but then she was also
starting to say that like bronwyn is now
because she's no longer drinking like
making everyone else's problems about
drinking and i didn't think that brahman
was doing anything
at all no and i think that's like a kind
of a mean thing to put out there that
it's like
just like that yeah well at the end of
the day what they're mad at bronwyn for
isn't that big of a deal so i really
feel like they could stand to have like
a little bit more compassion
for someone who's going through
something really really hard on tv
yeah and especially if you consider the
fact that what she said was probably
true and also when she said at kelly's
house she was like
normally in the past i would have just
been like oh yeah i probably got that
wrong and like
smoothed it over but she's like no i'm
gonna like stand up for myself right now
and i feel like she's getting that
that's the backbone now
she's literally saying what you said
like last year she was just like so
thirsty to be friends with everyone so
she would just like play whatever side
she was talking to
yeah which is a really spineless thing
yeah and so like she's has a spine now
yeah and i'm gonna i'm gonna root for
her yeah
no and like someone who like sees a
problem in their life
makes a change and does the hard work
and i'm gonna root for that person even
if they said something that someone said
and they threw shannon
right the bus and gina's house is sad
like yeah i'm gonna root for her
yeah i agree um but so it's really
turning out to be like a better season
than i thought
the new housewife i don't know if i said
who i thought she looked like yet
because
it came to me in a dream um she looks
like two people one she looks like vicki
gombelson that's literally vicki
fumbleson
and she also looks like dana 25 000 from
beverly hills housewives which by the
way they were playing
like season two beverly hills bravo on
bravo all day yesterday and it was
unbelievable oh that's so it's when kim
richards gets set up with that guy
martin
at muhammad hadid's house yeah it was
really like a true time capsule
i still think she reminds me energy wise
of the older sister
from privileged the show
abruptly after a cliffhanger it's on cw
seed
that is a treat the show is called
privilege with um joanna garcia
lucille and elizabeth stoppelganger
energy wise
also i ever said i thought you meant
that the third actress's name was
elizabeth stoppelganger no the third
actress name
is ashley something she she's in
hallmark movies now and she's
living the life she crushes it also i've
received a number of messages
confirming my call of kendall jenner
kendall jenner in the queen's gambit and
i
i would like you to reconsider my
position okay i've also seen a few
messages of people who thought that
queen's gambit beth looked a little bit
like taylor swift and i did see that too
in the face the lips yeah kendall
jenner's eyes taylor swift's lips
but can you i'll have to take a look i
can't just
visualize it i need to look at some
photos you know i've got very much
kendall jenner energy and i really
appreciate you guys
speaking about you sticking by me and
letting me it's it's one thing to agree
with me and it's one thing to like let
me know and make me feel like more
reassured and
in my wacky calls that have some merit
to them big time
big time um so that is our show
there is no show tomorrow because it is
the queen's birthday so it's actually
for the prince's birthday
um happy birthday jackie oh make sure
you follow her on instagram for
you know the birthday gift for yeah all
of the gifts also
um new episode of redheads just dropped
this morning it's a really fun episode i
was
editing it last night and it's like the
most podcasting we've ever been we're
usually a very book clubby like question
answer question answer
and this time you know we're being like
true podcasts talking over each other
and making fun of each other fabulous
so we love to see it even if you didn't
read the book it's just like
some good old-fashioned hang time and
i'm really excited
for next month's book we're reading the
invisible life of addie larue by
by ve schwab i've heard really good
things and so if you
are looking to become a redhead it is
never too late and in fact i do think
now is the perfect time
it's never a bad time thank you guys so
much for listening to the morning toast
millennial morning show where we deliver
the past five stories that you need to
know every monday through friday on
youtube
so if you're watching us on youtube
please feel free to subscribe and give
this video a thumbs up
we're also available as a podcast
anywhere podcasts can be found so that's
spotify itunes stitcher public radio i
heart radio cat box all the places
so wherever you listen to podcasts find
us the morning chosen leave a five star
review about how beautiful stunning and
smart we are we hope you have an amazing
day an amazing weekend stay safe wish
jackie you a happy birthday
and we will see you on monday
you